good evening and welcome thanks very
much for coming my name is Mark tribe
I'm the director of art and technology
here in the School of the Arts and I'm
very pleased to welcome you to the
Columbia art and Technology lectures
co-sponsored by the Digital Media Center
and the computer Music Center the goal
of this lecture series is to develop a
critical understanding of the cultural
effects and social consequences of the
intersection of art and emerging
technologies we have a few upcoming
lectures I'm just gonna scroll down on
Wednesday February 25th Chris
Csikszentmihalyi his name is really hard
to pronounce is gonna be speaking here
Chris runs the computing culture program
at the Media Lab at MIT up in Cambridge
and is a really interesting artist his
projects include DJI robot which is a
robotic DJ and also Afghan Explorer
which is a kind of tactical media
project he sent a robotic Explorer to
Afghanistan to create a kind of
independent media channel not unlike the
little robots earth calling around on
Mars
today Wednesday March 24th again here at
the Nieman gallery will be Paul Miller
also known as DJ Spooky that's the blue
little kid he's a conceptual artist and
he's got two books forthcoming from MIT
press on Wednesday April 8th manuel de
Landa manuel has published three books
war in the age of intelligent machines a
thousand years of nonlinear history and
most recently intensive science and
virtual math which is sort of de lives
for scientists and then last but
certainly not least ricardo Dominguez on
Wednesday May 12th which will be
upstairs in the lifetime screening room
Ricardo is also a tactical media artist
a member of the electronic disturbance
theater and a really interesting speaker
actually have a just one correction I
believe that Manuel de Wanda April 8
that's a Thursday that's the one that's
that's not a Wednesday night
Ricardo and I said he's a tactical media
artist and a member of electronic
disturbance theater and he's
collaborated actually with one of the
visual arts professors here Coco Fusco
using this Java applet called flood net
as a kind of electronic civil
disobedience - it's sort of like a
imagine a virtual sit-in against for
example the Mexican government in
support of the Zapatista rebels really
interesting kind of activist media
practice anyhow tonight's speaker is
Mary Flanagan I met Mary I guess it was
a year and a half ago at the Dutch
electronic art festival in Rotterdam
Mary was cooped up in a little structure
on the roof of this warehouse where she
was participating in this rather
grueling art experiment by Sarah diamond
who runs the Banff new media Institute
she was locked up for 24 hours in this
kind of roof rooftop architectural
project with a really eccentric British
inventor and they were talking in the
entire time and I was engaged to
interact with them or interlocutor with
them via a video chat after they'd been
in there for about 18 hours they were
talking a mile a minute but the video
connection we had had a tremendous delay
up about two minutes so it was really
one of the strangest but somehow most
interesting experiences I've had in
recent memory although some would say
that Mary Flanagan is an artist because
her work has been exhibited at the
Whitney Biennial and at galleries in New
York such as for Central fine arts it
might be more accurate to describe her
as a researcher in experimental cultural
practices and I hope we'll find out a
little bit more about those experiments
tonight her essays on digital art cyber
culture and gaming have appeared in
numerous journals and books and she's
the creator of a web-based game for
girls called The Adventures of Josie
true she is currently working on a
project to teach middle school girls
computer programming please join me in
offering a warm welcome to Mary
mmm thanks everybody I'm really excited
to start off this series it's a great
series I think you'll see me
people are really amazing speakers um
let me just close this and get a little
situated here find my talk yeah I
appreciate Mark's description because I
think a lot of times I as a resist being
categorized as an artist because of the
kinds of actors projects I do in the
writing that I do as well but tonight I
wanted to focus on artistic processes
and and and the art work and kind of
create because it's the inaugural you
know moment of this art technology
lecture series I originally had a title
for my talk space language in the
everyday systems the digital as a
material and I and I chucked that
although I kind of I'm interested in
these things what if because I think
that this idea that the kinds of the
kinds of intersections that I'm working
in really have a lot to do and and and
this is funny because I didn't really
talk about this with Mark about these
ideas of experimentation and about how
process scientific processes and
artistic processes have many many
similarities and how historically I
think new media is not different than a
lot of other art movements in in
foregrounding process and in
foregrounding these kinds of
experimental processes so I want to do a
little instead of just jumping right
into my work I wanted to kind of tie a
little history together of how I see my
work and and the kinds of work that I'm
interested in primarily web art
networked art these kinds of things and
I'll get to showing that in a sec I have
an entire hour and then questions so I
get to kind of to hold these things
hopefully help me like this
um digital art you know this is a
challenging field so so why is it
challenging it's really hard to describe
for a lot of reasons first of all
there's this sense that that it's always
changing it's always new there's always
new technology there's there's a sense
that the tools are difficult to use or
alternatively you have these the kind of
low-tech movement of people who are
wiring all the tarios together and still
the sense of all of those materials and
tools as arcane
and on the one hand or so high-tech that
they're inaccessible on the other hand
and people in this room probably sit
somewhere in the middle with with in the
middle of all of this but but mastering
the tools seems kind of difficult even
though they are everyday tools and a lot
of my work investigates the digital is
everyday I mean many of us are are in
this kind of relationship every day so
I'm very interested in this digital it
relies on language but it's not
necessarily the kind of language it's a
human created language different kinds
of computer programming code so also
digital artists kind of this strange
thing when I was in school I studied
filmmaking I did a vanguard kind of
experimental film and audio work and
there was no cultural industry you know
in the same way we didn't have a big MTV
was not quite the same to a video artist
as something like the software industry
but I think so so digital artists are
kind of working amidst this ubiquitous
consumption and and in commercialization
and and what I think is interesting as
many digital artists fluidly move
between those things and it's kind of
okay that that there isn't such a
distinct line between you know
commercial use of digital tools and and
personal artistic use so that's that's
another kind of theme that comes out and
maybe these are these are maybe seeds
for discussion for later the
questionable economic position of
digital art lots of models for that you
have artists who are making kind of
standalone works that can be sold as an
as an object you have limited edition
installations these kinds of things I've
mark America tried to eBay his
interactive novel for $25,000 and never
saw this but but so collecting all the
all those valuable value things are
really challenging and then also this
this idea that digital art the the
people who are coming to talk in this
series are thinking about this tactical
media we're part of a popular culture
and and that is a really important
kind of thing if we can't separate if
you're showing your work on the web you
can't separate your work from amazon.com
it's it's part of this you can call it
mean pool or whatever you want to call
it but it's all in that and so it is
it's in conversation with those things
so those are just themes about digital
material that I find particularly
fascinating but I want to just kind of
do a real quick slideshow for there
there there are some folks who kind of
look at digital media as a particularly
new new phenomenon our new form and I
just like to always go back to two
things like the surrealist the
surrealist this is an image of a Takei
ting what one thing that fascinates me
about the surrealist and how it relates
to the digital art and interactive
artists right now is the kind of
incorporation of gaming practices as
research methodologies the use of
exquisite corpse drawings the practice
and the process of exquisite quarry it's
a little right it kind of so these kind
of group practices investigating process
and we could say experimentation because
we have lots of different kinds of
drawings and things that have come out
of a group process and you see a lot of
digital artist collectives also working
in this way where people are working off
of each other's code or hacking on each
other's pieces so I like to go back to
this and also this this interactivity
this engagement either with your own
process or with with the user I think
both of those kinds of roles of play and
really come and come in to practice I
also like to look at Alan Capra's work
you know he defined happenings in 1959
and a lot of these are some kind of
documentation and instructions from
happenings here as his work yard in 1961
a lot of his work site-specific work I
mean I'm probably talking to a lot of
artists who know this work really well
but you wouldn't necessarily tie it to
digital media things being plugged in
and I really do and I do because there's
the sense of engaging in the everyday
engaging and going out in the world and
having some kind of encounter I think
that you find these kinds of themes
throughout did
artworks and that's pretty exciting
Claes Oldenburg the store there many of
my students when they're making digital
artworks want to create alternate stores
as artworks this is an interesting
phenomenon that I've seen because a lot
of people want to learn technical skills
like they had a basis and things and and
programming but but they also want to do
some culture hacking so there's a sense
of making artificial stores or
artificial portals and I and I just
think back to Claes Oldenburg and his
interactive work the store where he
would he would work inside the store and
you know this kind of installation and
this performative space and do exchanges
of objects and things like this we have
Rauschenberg and Hays eight Performance
different kinds of I look at these these
these works even though they're very
physical in a lot of ways III don't see
them really thematically very different
especially things like found objects and
found found sound objects for example
right here we have you know Alison orals
bean rolls so this is kind of a sound
object but it also has things to read in
there and and these works from flexus
are very important I think in terms of
situating digital art in a larger a
larger whole instruction paintings yoko
owners instruction paintings very
interesting i I have my students
actually make instruction paintings
before they create artwork
digital artwork because they're really
it's basically pseudocode right it's
basically a pseudo code of how you would
program something you're basically
giving instructions on how to create a
work so this is a program if you want to
come with me on that little jaunt and I
I think that in this kind of work from
the sixties on has been really
informative in terms of accepting sets
of instruction and if you've seen the
latest code duck show at the Whitney the
Whitney Museum created by Christiana
Paul where the work of the artist is the
code if you go online to the Whitney and
you go to their their the site the
actual artworks produced by the code
isn't the work it's
the actual code becomes the work of art
and several people in the audience here
I see have been in that show in one form
or another been but I think it seems
like such a radical idea they're showing
in computer code in the Whitney but it
but when I think when you look at this
kind of material is not so surprising I
I went to Nam June Paik in my kind of
spewing history of where I'm coming from
and all this stuff because I I started
thinking about performative objects and
performative spaces that are also tied
to the body and tied to kind of live
performance and I thought this one
looking at video art was also a big part
of this and Lynn Hirshman is Lorna the
interactive video disc we're
groundbreaking work where you can
interact with laurynas talking head and
this is 19th 1970s to 1980s so so I this
is kind of getting to know a character
and the chronic questions about identity
that seems so new in the 1990s cyberpunk
cyber cyber stuff I want to jump just a
little bit because there may be there
there may be people in the audience
coming from a finance background and
saying okay well that history is ok
right it's it's it's it's a it's we
could figure out that those kinds of
conceptual art you know games or
performances or what I released were
these interactions we're experiments as
to kind of question what art is where is
what is the role of you or all of those
kinds of things but what what happens
when you mix that with technology are
inherently bound
I'm literally bound just to UM to
science and engineering and so then I
then the kind of the question comes up
how do how does science and engineering
and these in this kind of tradition of
our practice start to start to mingle
and I I want to look here at Vannevar
Bush because Vannevar Bush was kind of a
many of you probably know MIT wiz who
created lots of different inventions he
they're great inventions like he hooked
up bicycle wheels and like ran up hills
and did lots of tinkering as well as
kind of more sophisticated devices such
as this Memex which was never created
but it was it was a plan for basically
kind of a microfilm machine that really
ended up being kind of like a model for
a computer it was a kind of a vision of
the workstation of the future that was
conceived in 1945 and then he had a
different kinds of things walnut cameras
and you know I wonder when Steve Mann
the artist who is always on Kent has
cameras on and all the time on his
glasses I wonder when in his life he saw
that as a young talent like once the
walnut camera on one's head but but
these are experiments these is okay what
if I have a camera tied to my head what
happens these are these are questions
that artists and scientists ask
themselves in the same way you could
look at someone like Steve Mann who's at
the University of Toronto who is from
MIT and ask the same question the
process by which they come to the answer
though may be a different process and
that's kind of where I want to I want to
take this talk this is in the dark here
we see space war which is touted as the
first computer game and I I in my head I
cannot divorce interactive art
especially screen based art but many men
even installations from gaming and from
computer gaming because I think that
there are so many ways in which the idea
of play and interactivity is brought up
in any kind of interactive environment
and we could look at Brian cent and
Smith's work or other game theorists not
game theory but anthropological studies
of play to to to find that that there's
a really interesting thing that happens
in any kind of creative process and I
think when we look at the way that
computer games have evolved very much
parallel to digital art there's a lot of
dialogues and we're seeing this more and
more the Machinima movement where
artists are doing a lot of computer game
engine hacks this is this is
been constant and I just didn't we're
almost done with the history hang on a
couple more things
Tony Conrad's Flickr film is a it's a
it's a pretty a pretty important way
that structuralist filmmaking or
structuralist for formalists aesthetics
from from from kind of more traditional
image making such as linear movies i
think could be thought of as interactive
work and invoking real physical
responses or invoking these kinds of
things
the flickr film if you haven't seen it
is four frames of black four frames of
white four frames of clear four frames
of black clear and it flickers and it
can cause a epileptic seizure and it's
you know this is kind of controversial
and then when the Pokemon thing was
doing it in Japan everybody they flew I
was working with Tony at the time and
they flew him over to Japan as soon as
the pokmon like seizure thing hit
because he he was so I can hot demand
anyway it's hard to display the flickr
film unless you're actually experiencing
a flicker if I could have you know made
a little flash and I mean I just we can
imagine flashing light okay so I why I
why I bring Tony Conrad's work up is I
there there are certain kinds of video
work that didn't involve necessarily
like interfaces or like lorna lin
Hirshman lisa she's learned her lisa now
involve interfaces and kind of tangible
interactivity or decision-making but
there are still this kind of sense of
evoking some kind of participatory
response in a pretty pretty visceral way
Harold Cohen from UC San Diego created
Aaron which is this artificial
intelligence painting system in 1973
when he actually wrote scientific papers
about the problems in making paintings
you know make artificial artworks what
are the inherent problems and artificial
artworks most of the art that he talked
about in this 1973 article was about
just kind of image processing most of
the most
the work that was using computers at
this time was kind of just for image
processing you want to take one kind of
image and make it into Oh what are those
large wall picture things where you have
all the little pictures and it's like
all your family snapshots but it ends up
being a whole family picture you know
that was Madonna yes there are these
kinds of experiments and and and and
things but in late 60s early 70s and a
lot of that was called computer art and
and that's kind of where people took it
and he wanted to take a little further
and develop this artificial intelligence
system that actually painted and then
started selling the paintings and I
think it's a really interesting subject
for looking at at you know who's the
author and this kind of thing that I
think you'll find in a lot of
screen-based work as well and so that's
those are the kind of not like not
necessarily traditionally thought about
as digital artworks but I think that
you'll see a lot of the themes of
experimentation and the themes of
interactivity coming out and the the
range of pieces I just showed I want to
now show just contextualize some of the
important works I think in the field
right now for example from the 90s on
some some virtual environments and a few
other things just to give a little taste
for people who aren't necessarily
familiar with this work David wrote be
the giver of names is a project where
it's an installation where there are
objects all around the room and you can
wander up to an object and pick an
object up and put it on a pedestal and
then the computer will try to name it
it's like it's uh it's telephone it's uh
you know it tries to figure out what it
is and and and I hear here's some
distant image so this is its process you
know you're kind of watching it and he
he kind of I think I have a description
of exactly what what he's got he's got a
metaphorically linked associative
database of known objects ideas and
sensations the words Wow there's another
phone in there
the words and uh so so anyway so it
David wrote me is trying to created what
he calls a state of mind about the
objects so he's he's he's trying to say
okay can't can is this is this kind of a
consciousness is the ability to name
something consciousness or not it's like
my son track before I started talking
it's at the computer game center this so
this is the kind one kind of question
then is this physical relationship to
the physical world this idea that that
objects in the world can be processed by
kind of consciousnesses that are
computers and and then renamed and and
that interaction with the physical world
is pretty interesting I think Shara
Davies I want to point out as someone in
digital art who does amazing virtual
environments if you haven't ever seen
her work please try to she had a really
big show in San Cisco recently um she
has these wonderfully abstract virtual
environments and you actually wear and
kind of a vest and the the program
actually tracks your breathing and how
you navigate around in the space is
actually by your breath and by your
balance and not through saying run here
go here and so you kind of float in and
go through this process and many people
who go into these worlds have you know
they've come out crying and they it's
it's a head-mounted display kind of kind
of VR experience and here's some images
she has two of them Osmos an FM air from
the 90s and so I mean one of the things
I think that if you would want to look
at this idea of experimentation David
wrote me saying okay well what if what
if computers had this kind of
consciousness that could that could name
things I could recognize things you know
what is that relationship between that
and I mean it's very easy to see is
looking at ideas about God as well as
about human power and I think that the
work of Shar Davies is very different
it's looking at the physical experience
of being in in a world in some kind of
world maybe of artificial world and is
that as compelling or more so than the
physical world we have around us there's
some more images of Ruth
yes that's pretty light Christa summer
and Lauren Megan ooh have a really great
work called evolve which is the little
creatures and in a pool that that
evolved and based on where users kind of
it's a literally like a liquid pool like
a pool of and users can kind of reach
out and the creatures their virtual
creatures that are projected into the
pool they change and grow through
through through touch and here's little
critters that are in the pool and this
this work is actually up in Boston right
now I've heard that there's a of that
this work I think is really interesting
at wardo cats and leash a Nick Amaro
Nakamura did this project which I think
I I think this project is one of the
projects that has influenced me the most
in the last five years and I'm not
exactly sure why but I'll describe it
that the bird was located in Kentucky
and the bird would sing and the plant
would would they did this over phone
lines the plant would listen to the
birds music in New York through the
speaker and then there are little bio
feedback mechanisms put on the leaves of
the plant and the that would also feed
into a computer which processed the
audio from the bird with the feedback of
the plant and sent it back to the bird
who responded back to the plants and
there's this loop and I don't know how
long they had it going because it really
uh you know ran on a phone they actually
called I don't think it was even really
doing much like modem I think it was a
phone call but it was not it was not
visual it was it was audio mm-hm
and there's just something for me
there's something really magical about
this system that evolved and changed and
had really at some point very very few
rules inside of it except for it but the
key the key part of this piece of course
is how are you making that translation
how are you interpreting the data which
is kind of a scientific question too if
you are doing a scientific
why are you interpreting the data from
the plant and giving it meaning how are
you putting that into some like
processor or sampler and and seeing what
kind of meaning that that produces or
what kind of tone I mean anyone doing
sonification projects just like
visualization projects color color if
you're trying to map a windstorm it
really is an arbitrary choice and and
how do you do that let's say you're
going to do sonification project where
you're mapping a windstorm how do you
know that wind speed should equal
velocity so this mapping process that is
a scientific question also is a really
an interesting artists question
especially in a lot of digital and
interactive work where you have a system
that's almost running on its own it's
almost an autonomous system but but
those choices take on great import
here's a little chart of this little we
can skip that John Simon's work I find
really interesting and I'm just going to
run through a couple of these Josh on
they rule which is this visualization
project of boards of directors of other
companies so you can real data so you
can click on them on the board of
directors of Time Warner and see and if
someone is fat they they're on several
boards of directors
I'm sorry large and and and Lisa you
have grant also does really cool stuff
where she makes little web crawlers that
go out and trace all the linked web
pages for example it's kind of web
visualization stuff and Natalie Butch
Jones another artist who talks about
this this is like a little VR virtual
pet game that you train this little
character to and someone here will
actually have all these links I can make
these links available if people are want
to spend time with these works because
they're most of them at this point are
on the web from this apart on in my talk
are on the web and easily found so this
idea of interacting with you you run
this little kind of creature in this
company kind of nurture it and then you
then you kind of get it to be happy and
you can drug it and they're all these
kind of and it works for a bio bio
pharmaceutical kind of corporation and
and and Natalie books in really sees it
as this kind of activist game where
where you're kind of always being forced
to answer these ethical questions that
everyone kind of wants to avoid if it's
if it's a you know that the user has to
make ethical questions about the worker
in an uncomfortable way and I found it
uncomfortable so this is Mark Napier's
piece riot which goes around the web and
makes collages out of visited websites
depending on where what websites you
visit when you're looking at it and then
I'm gonna move on to my work now so I
hope you to come on through all of that
um one of the things I'm really
interested in I guess the overall theme
of my work and it's only come to me from
having made it I can't say I started out
saying I pledge that I will make work
about the everyday and I will be a
tactical media artist or something like
this I I had no idea the kind of the
kind of trajectory that I was working in
really except to spell out what I find
fascinating and and looking back I I
start to see that it that that kind of
this our toes practice of everyday life
and looking at looking at kind of power
relations and uncovering the ways in
which power relations or kind of current
structures and strategies don't absorb a
society and so I I think that one of the
one of the important things that isn't a
controlled space right now still is kind
of this tactical or web-based art this
stuff is out there it's free I give my
work away I want it to spread I want it
to be viral and that and and I know I'm
I don't necessarily make work to show in
a gallery I I like it to kind of go out
I and you know sometimes it's anonymous
most of the time lately it hasn't been
but there sometimes it is so so this way
that that we can kind of get back to the
what is what is our experience in the
everyday and that's when I start looking
at the computer because I my question is
okay I
sit in front of a computer every day 54%
of Americans have computers at home and
use them over four hours a week so many
of us have the experience of sitting in
front of a computer every day so what is
this experience how can we look at this
relationship and we could just one time
I did this virtual performance piece and
at the in some University in Georgia and
several faculty mean it was a virtual
performance piece I had to perform this
stuff in this 3d space and I used a
mouse and the faculty member came up to
me afterwards he was a performance
studies faculty and he said that wasn't
a performance that was not a performance
and I said well it was there are other
people in the space we were all
interacting we have we have dialogue and
lines and sound happening and all this
stuff and he said no it wasn't all you
were doing was this and I realize you
know wow there's there's some serious
gaps between how but but then what is
that happen let's talk about that you
know like what is that you know if my
daily experience with other people is
this kind of it is strange they have to
say I want to look at that in depth and
so the first kind of this is some
virtual performance stuff I used to do a
lot of VRML pieces this a lot of my
early work work kind of everyday stories
and I worked for a while in the software
industry and I wanted to I wanted to
just get out of the whole high tech
thing and say okay what are real people
doing with this stuff
I don't read stories about old women for
example online you know I don't read
stories I don't find this materials
right so I made a piece about my
grandmother who was in the hospital and
it's called the perpetual bed and it's
this three dimensional thermal
environment one of the reasons I'm not
showing it live is because it's a verbal
environment and VRML virtual reality
reality modeling language is really an
unstable lost in some ways technology
especially on the Mac and which brings
up kind of an interesting point maybe
this is more like performance than we
even thought if we if it
through documentation and scores and it
kind of a question I want spend that
much time on the early work so we can
get to seeing some some of the more
interactive stuff but I've done some
physical installations looking at the
space looking looking at physical space
if I'm making virtual spaces how can I
look at physical space and and explore
issues so this is a installation where
you walk towards these kind of
stereotypical images of women in
corporate America women at work and they
start to blur out when you approach them
but if you kind of backup and stand 30
feet away they're very clear and it's
kind of playing I was trying to try to
create a spatialization of of the idea
of the glass ceiling and tried kind of
like discussing in the issue of some
something like the glass ceiling is
really difficult to have a very clear
conversation about with coworkers or
it's very difficult you can cite facts
and things like that but it's a cloudy
issue so I was trying to just do a
spatial version of this this is a board
game called career moves which it's a
multi-user physical board game where
embedded into the board or all these
little doll pieces like little baby
laptops and little like cell phones and
CD ROMs and things and you you go around
the board playing and it's kind of like
chutes and ladders meets operation you
you try to reach into the little holes
and get these little objects but if you
hit the side with your little you know
your little metal tongs you get self
help kind of Corporate America coaching
for women in corporate environments you
know be strong and it's all found audio
stuff it's so mostly it's an audio piece
actually and but it's also a social
experiment again one of those kind of
what happens when you make a game that
doesn't have an end III didn't put a win
on there I didn't I didn't you don't
finish you start playing and there's no
end and then that's very interesting
what happens because people start to
make their own collaborative decisions
about what means what does winning mean
in this
so and it's great to watch people so a
group of kids might go around the board
and they might say okay whoever gets the
most stuff wins and they go and collect
all the objects and then another group
might say okay
academics mostly tend to say whoever is
CEO wins and so this kind of
collaborative rulemaking system I think
is very interesting and something I
would like to continue doing work
investigating the project rulings is
something I made in 2001 which has 11
different interactive games and I can
actually show that live if if our
internet connection is running actually
you know what I'll do first I'll rewind
a little bit and talk about a project
from 1999 2000 2001 but I have to open
up Virtual PC so we have to be nice to
the Mac let's see how that there we go
one of the projects that I did in 1999
was called phage and I was interested in
computer viruses and how computer
viruses seemed to be invasive and very
frightening and all this hype about
computer viruses and now boy today it
was really bad actually in terms of
computer virus reception but I was very
interested in computer viruses and I was
very interested in the space of the hard
drive because I started making a lot of
virtual environments and 3d spaces and I
said well what is the space in this
thing you know how how can I map this
and and if I were Rachel Whiteread I'd
cast the inside but I but I I'm not and
so how would i how do i how do i
investigate the kind of this everyday
what's what's in this space and and what
is a hard interior of a hard drive look
like what kind of how could i map it
what would that be like so i created
this program that goes through the users
hard drive and grabs bits and pieces of
your stuff and puts it in a moving 3d
world and
trying to come up with some alternative
map because I was also making a critique
of the operating system we use these
operating systems and all of these
pieces of software all the time and the
a lot of times people don't question the
kind of hierarchies and structures that
are embedded in that software the values
that are embedded in the software we
kind of take it for granted but really
there's there are mindsets and
worldviews of people who make things
that I think it embedded into the things
we that we use so and that's true for
what I make and I think it's true for
for a lot of things I don't think that
that technological products are neutral
so so I made this project to see well
what would happen if if we could make
this kind of map what would it be like
so I'm running it in Virtual PC because
it runs on the PC and let's just hope it
it likes to run in the Virtual PC this
this project is showing at the
Guggenheim in March in a show with
curated by John apellido called
something about software emulation show
so it's actually going to be running on
a Mac and a PC one is an emulation and
it's I there's a lot of talk and
curatorial circles about how do you
archive this work this what is this work
this work feeds off of content off of a
hard drive runs in a particular
operating system in ten years when we
may not even have the same file formats
I find sound to this this this work also
raises a lot of copyright questions too
right and because it's the work is
really only consisting of what it finds
so therefore oops Windows is I'm
fighting with Windows in a Mac isn't it
cool okay come on oh we're gonna have to
show this later you just witness the
weirdest thing okay we'll go back to my
talk we had a moment of the project
working
I tried to resize the window then
windows restarted on the Mac ah blue
screen of death okay let's go let's go
back let's go back to the other now my
mouth because because it's true this is
what I but I don't for presentations
sake
I appreciate the audience's need to have
you know something slick and nice but I
feel as though representing this
material primarily on video or making it
kind of slick and not actually trying to
go on the web and trying to run the
things I feel is artificial I feel it's
really false that's not what the work is
not experienced that way by most users
the work is kind of experienced this way
by a lot of users and I think there's
it's part of I think it's part of the
work I you know it's bad when it crashes
yes but it's also this kind of it's also
really important I think in terms of in
terms of what this like the unstable
media that that data that I put that
lets I'm gonna have to like occasionally
check back on my on my little on my
little guy here hold on okay let me just
it is hair-raising definitely that's not
fun or anything I'm just saying it is
part of the material I don't have to
like that
clay is sticky okay okay so that so that
work when we see it will be um well it's
this kind of moving specialized map of
the hard drive then I made a version of
it that was a networked version that
pulled stuff off of different people's
hard drives and started pulling it
together this work is called routing z--
Wow
this work is called routing x' and it's
a it's a series of of several different
arcade games and we can see it on my
website live and it's created in flash
and basically what I've got here is sets
of games that tell kind of little
personal stories everyday stories about
time and memory so I there are different
all these little kind of arcade style
games are in here different different
little things here's one this one
stories about nightmares at night so
this is a piece of a little the game
called it's like a little game engine I
make called near asteroids and you kind
of shoot the narrative out as you as you
are playing and I would imagine and you
can fly around um again kind of
subverting gaming conventions though one
that one of the funny things is if you
if you hurry up and try to win the game
and shoot all the asteroids you start to
miss the story or if you you know people
will play it again and again and start
purposefully trying to not shoot the
asteroids and if the game becomes the
inverse of asteroids while people are
trying to read the text so so it's it's
just again this experiment of saying
well what what if you completely
inverted
the same kind of game and just change to
change one or two of the of the real
parameters so now you really don't want
to shoot these things because you want
to read the story and then when you
aren't when you're done you know you can
you can I should finish okay okay and
then you can go back to your interface
or you can go on to another game it can
take you take you through that so this
this
about I took letters from friends
letters from grandmother letters from
family members and and created different
kinds of games this is a game where my
grandmother wrote me a letter saying
that she was really bored she was about
94 and there was nothing that she could
do anymore except shop and but she said
but there was nothing left to buy and
that the so that's what we kind of we're
kind of shopping around and and piecing
together the letter at the bottom which
with this light you can't really read
and so so okay where's my steak or
whatever I'm supposed to collect I need
my tomatoes shoot so not only are we
having computer crash but I have to win
the game in front of everybody see
there's a lot of stress in my tomatoes
okay anyway you get there you get the
idea you get the idea so so this this
kinds of experiments in experiments in
kind of storytelling through
arcade-style games and rule changing but
that's I'd say how I would describe that
piece let's go back let's go back to you
know what Wow yes don't don't send okay
okay sorry for all of our windows okay I
have to find where I put it
and I promise when I touch it I won't
touch anything else okay so this piece
runs on one computer alone and the
project collection runs on networked
computers sorry we have a bunch of
windows opened did anyone ever see that
is it a Jody piece about about Windows
yes
Oh somebody said um then I'll say it is
two votes with there's this kind of
piece because all of these works are
always seen in these windows a piece
kind of interesting work that you you go
visit the piece and it's it just keeps
making more windows and it makes more
windows and more windows and more
windows and more windows until your
computer crashes so when I'm teaching I
try to show that at the end of class
because you know so what it's doing
right now is it's going through the hard
drive and grabbing different bits of
I think it's only going through my
windows portion of my of my hard drive
here it will go through email it will go
through you know Word documents letters
to your friends pictures that you've
downloaded cache files from the internet
things that are under a megabyte I have
it set for right now so that it doesn't
kind of eat everything and crash but but
it can get it can get larger but one of
the one of the things that's kind of
interesting is the longer that you use
your computer and the more files you
have on it the more fodder it has to
make these works and it starts to the
the it starts to reflect the person very
distinctly and I had not intended that
at all I was trying to make this kind of
conceptual map of the hard drive and
this piece starts becoming more and more
about whoever's computer it's on if
people have visited a lot of pornography
if people have you know they like to
shop for shirts or whatever these
materials keep coming up and coming up
and when I first made the piece my my
graduate assistant ran it out of his
computer and got
very upset and shut the computer off ooh
that's really ugly
maybe brick maybe ever gonna just well
let's see what happens um he he ran on
his computer and then he said gosh you
know I I hate this project he shut it
off he said I never wanted to have this
run on my computer again and I said well
why tell me what happened what what did
you not like about it and he said a
piece of mail from I don't remember what
this was originally made in 1989 so a
piece of mail from 1994 appeared so
snippet of his email appeared in front
of him on his screen and he was it was a
fight that he had had with a friend and
it was the last correspondence he'd ever
had with this friend and this brought
all of the stuff back just seeing the
snippet of these words come out and he
could identify it right away I would
never have identified what that was the
only thing that this does is also goes
through source code and different kinds
of source code HTML and it goes through
help files so suddenly the entire team
of Adobe Photoshop who've written the
the you know License Agreement and help
file become part of this authoring
environment where your so it's kind of
separate the whole artificial separation
between your work someone else's work
between between code and between other
kind of languages it's all being mixed
up here and and I think that's pretty
important to do okay I only have a few
more minutes so what I want to do is
quit Virtual PC really badly
I just guard hard drive changes and I'm
going to show you a few more things
no bad okay so we've seen this page I'll
show you search search is a project that
I did in 2001 oops
should always go to my menu
I did in 2001 that monitors people's use
of search engines because my question at
that point my little experiment for
myself was well what do we do every day
on the computer we use a search engine
and we use email
so I made this little project that goes
out on the web and monitors search
engine searches yes allow you should get
another warning box about allowing so
this is this is monitoring search engine
search live it goes out every 15 seconds
grabs people's searches and comes back
and we can watch them and then what we
can do here is we can say okay I want to
click on salvia and Johnny or Miller
web okay so so then what happens is it
takes this so basically I'm thinking
about language and desire okay the
question here is language and desire and
how we try to describe our daily desires
our daily needs
you are definitely Wow
I got a good 15 seconds here 15 okay
I'll try you can be an amused for a long
time I guess um but wait there's more no
that's that's only part of it that the
what what what starts happening is that
you become really fascinated with other
people's use of this stuff right you
start and the misspellings and you it
this like voyeur sensibility about these
peoples languages and you're kind of
wondering a gosh of mine is gonna show
up perhaps and what did I what did I
just type in and all of these kinds of
naughty things or whatever boring things
one is my class or I don't know so what
happens is you go out like I need some
more search terms here though let's
let's addition oh shoot story boy okay
this is another copyright and kind of
legal question that we could talk about
in our inner in our conversation okay so
wait so we're people have to spell
something correctly no okay copies so
what happens is it goes out and it goes
to a thesaurus database and starts
making a spinning thesaurus kind of
search so meshwork comes out of the word
web and let's say I really like the word
meshwork and I want to drag it and I
want
yeah a meshwork carbon what are my
associations with meshwork carbon and
this goes out into a cognitive
linguistic database and starts doing
associative database searches with those
two words and then you can keep doing
this so you can create this whole web of
interrelated words that you find
particularly interesting from this kind
of pop culture stream that's happening
alive and create your own searches one
of the interesting responses I got to
this was if people wanted a lot of
people want to use it and they do use it
as a brainstorming tool to just when
people are stuck for ideas or writers
they start pulling two and two together
and creating these strange combinations
of wonder with me never mind
but that's so that's this kind of search
engine piece and looking at things that
we do every day and trying to ask for
what what if we saw it differently how
do we how can we how can we shift what's
going on there I'm doing a current piece
the two the two that I came up with
which were the most common things were
email and search engines weren't for it
but this is what my mother would use a
computer for and solitaire which is
another question entirely about the
gaming contemporary gaming and this this
is kind of a game but you know it's not
a traditional game in this sense of
winning but it's definitely this kind of
sorting and moving around and and and
play involved the current project that
I'm doing that I'll say off of this
because it's related is is is an email
project where I'm collaborating with a
friend to map sets of correspondences
between two people so you email me I'm
you email you and we've been emailing
each other for a year or maybe only two
weeks and maybe you are my friend but I
email you and we've never met so may I
it's kind of looking at the idea of
voice and and how do we how do how does
our language change in email between you
and between people you know people you
work with people you're kind of
officially and related to people you're
very friends with and can we make a kind
of sound signature sound map out of
people's emails almost like this voice
in the head you know when
reading someone's email you kind of hear
this it's just this but we're doing this
so often with so many different people I
mean compared to the kinds of
correspondences people used to get in
text on letters I think that just the
volume of so many different kinds of
emails and all of these different kind
of voices in our heads and how we're
constructing these people as subjects
and relating to people and constructing
our own language so then so this project
this is a sound project it's it's not a
visual project it's a sound project
that's doing kind of generative sound
based on these sound signatures
depending on who people are
corresponding with sets of different
people but I don't have anything to show
on that because it sounds like a right
now it doesn't sound so good yet because
it's just beginning I'm just beginning
to do that and the last piece I think I
want to just mention is my piece I did
this fall last fall that showed in
Australia called domestic and you did
some smaller images I have larger images
in here I think yeah here's here's a
larger image these are game engine hacks
of the Unreal Engine and which I'm
trying to tell a story from my childhood
so using 3d action game with guns and
death and taking all the guns and death
hopefully out of it and trying to use it
as a storytelling medium so it's it's a
story about the time when I was 10 years
old my father set the house on fire and
it's and it was it was a pretty weird
thing so so you kind of wander through
and after it was finished I showed it
and I showed it in Australia and I
started to feel like an installation to
me almost many people have mentioned
that it feels more like an installation
than a game and I said well is it just
because of the content or you know I'm
an artist or what about it what about
the texture of this piece is it the
sound what and and I don't I don't
really know so I'm still investigating
that what happens in the game is that
you you run around and you you can shoot
coping
mechanisms at the walls so like you can
shoot you can shoot splat oops um don't
mean to damage your nice screen but yeah
you can shoot these like beer bottles
and romance novels and things on the
wall and and in kinda and then they fade
away and and then this in version two
you can shoot them at the fire because
the fire starts to consume the whole 3d
structure and and that's ultimately when
you lose a game but you can fight it off
and you can kind of try to contain it
but it spreads and you can fight fight
it that way but that's that's version
true that's coming in about two months
that all the fire will be finished so
these hopefully III think to wrap up
what I want to do is just mention this
idea to reiterate my idea of this what
if this Arden's artists and science
process I mean I I've given you a very
strange probably slice of kind of
contemporary art practices and digital
art practices but I feel like this is
going to be a very different kind of
narrative than say Paul Miller would
give and I and that's why I think the
lecture series is going to be really
exciting you could look at all kinds of
art and Technology combinations that I
have not touched on at all you could
look at you know where is stellar and
and where are cyborgs and where are
there are so many different places to
look at art science combinations you
know robotics and Simon Penny's work all
there's its if there's a lot of stuff
but I'm primarily looking at things that
are that are emergent that have
unexpected outcomes that are most of the
stuff I'm interested in a screen based
in some way because I think that is the
material of what we're working with and
it doesn't mean that I as an artist
don't like to make stuff I do like to
make you know things and and spaces but
the material is is particularly
interesting and then how do you exhibit
this work if it's made for a screen and
you want to put it in something in a
gallery you know that I know Brad Paley
is coming for the master planner because
you have these great screen but but but
you know when people approach this
object they say oh nice g4 and ice
oh look at the work on it you know so
that there's this whole I mean who would
ever do that to a frame of us as in
right like it's like no you would look
at the worst so that's a it's very
strange and I and I like that I think
it's really part of this material and it
fascinates me and and how we are
interfacing you know through these
products is is it's really fascinating
and and I think I think it just has a
lot of meaning it can tell us a lot more
about popular culture and about artistic
practice looking in those kind of spaces
than maybe some of the traditional
spaces only because it's such a fluid
and fastly affective just evolving place
and that's why I find it powerful but to
end I want to talk about reflective
practice to people know Donald Sean's
work I recommend this I recommend this
book reflective practitioner it's
basically a practitioner designer
looking at how in primarily in design
fields but artists can easily use this
use this research to look at how how
practice is a ism is a research
methodology and how play he also starts
to conclude that play as a research
methodology is is particularly
appropriate and practice based works and
also looks and compares people for
example in architecture with scientists
let's say chemists how how do their
processes how are they similar and how
are they different and and he really
concludes with a lot of saying that that
the idea of creating an experiment
creating having a hypothesis coming up
with the you know I'm not an
anthropologist but somebody could say
I'm doing a either cultural studies of
the web or an anthropological studies of
the use of language and online community
you could come up with all kinds of ways
to position this work and I think it's
just how you're going to use it i don't
i don't run user studies on the work to
do so you know statistical analysis
about how many people clicked on the
word orgy in the search engine is died i
don't do that kind of that kind of
research but i think that these are
kind of research tools as well and I and
I don't exactly have an answer from what
it will conclude yet I think I think
time will tell us I keep making this
work what kind of I feel there's
definitely a research methodology
happening and there's definitely a
process of investigation
I don't know if the works themselves are
the only conclusion and I'll just I'll
just say that as as kind of a wrapping
pondering note and I didn't talk at all
about any of the kind of activist design
stuff I do and the games for girls in
any of that so we when we have question
to answer if you're interested in that
we could talk about that stuff but I
just wanted to spend some time with this
work thank you
so do you have questions yes well I mean
how I would cognitively oh definitely
this I I described this work as
investigations into everyday practices
of digital culture I mean that's what I
think I'm doing it
like looking and specifically looking at
how spatial paradigms come out so for
example if I were going to pick up a
feminist cultural geography in a way of
a particular position that I'm looking
at these spaces because even though a
lot of my work deals with text in a in
this kind of world I think that may be a
space so that's that's kind of how I
would overall conceptually position my
work as far as the research outcomes or
the research kind of vet investigation I
think that there's there's just a
different I just think that the maybe
the just the difference between research
that something like this and research
for example if I was trying to figure
out what do people if I just position
the question differently instead of
saying how do people use the search
engine you know if I just change the
shift the question I think I'm trying to
come at the experience of I'm trying to
create an experience of that space or of
of those particular everyday themes and
I I particularly like the everyday
because it's so unclear us and it's so
not high-tech you know for so long every
day stories and and and and just kind of
banal uses of technology we're not
really that was you know so many kind of
whiz-bang cool computer graphics go to
SIGGRAPH or something like that I really
wasn't interested in kind of creating
that the this like beautiful looking
a realistic kind of work I really am
interested in these kinds of have
everyday habits and and everyday spaces
of those habits and so that's I I think
that if I were to want one thing I with
many of these works I still I'm
interested for example I think that that
search engine piece is is like a tip of
an iceberg that could keep going as far
as different kinds of research like you
could look at simultaneous searches and
various cultures you could look around
the around the globe and say okay well
how do these how do the searches compare
in different places you could also start
looking at images and the kinds of of
imaginaries that come out of the
searches tying languages to tang
language to images and things but I also
have to say that I as someone who works
in this medium I think I have a short
attention span and I think I I think
I've seen some some artist who's you
know like like Harold Cohen and that
Erin thing but they were together for a
long time and I I'm not I'm not
interested in that level of in
investigation the level of commitment
and because I think that the technology
is always changing so if you stick
yourself into I'm the search engine
person I think you can easily get stuck
into into a not being able to change
with the technology it's more like it's
more like the work fits the material in
turn in the terms of the digital the
things are tactical and they're fast and
they're light and they're they're quite
mobile I think if you spent two years or
three years creating in digital artwork
by the you know if you really set and
created that kind of scale of a work I
think for the most part it would
probably be it might have a lot of
issues and you might have lost a lot of
time because it depends on what you're
examining because things change so
quickly so it so these I think these
pieces are quite light in terms of their
their nimbleness I they're they're not
huge trying to define what all searches
are to all people they're they're kind
of examinations or even experiments on
on these themes
can go further on that later but yes oh
oh I don't think it does at all I don't
think I'm interested in artuz
experimentation because it's good to do
or something or I'm somehow obedient I
think it's I think it's because I like I
like asking questions and and examining
things and I think that interactivity
tends to have a lot of that sense a lot
of interactive works are saying well
what it because there's this whole
uncontrolled public who can do all these
things to your work and that's
pleasurable if you're not interested in
that kind of level of play and
experimentation you wouldn't be making
that kind of work so it's kind of bound
up in that but the critique of trying to
it's it's a valuable critique and
especially in the UK and in Australia
where there are a lot of practice based
PhD programs and many artists are kind
of trying to do quantitative analysis on
user feedback after they visit an
installation I've seen this kind of
trying to do data and and even people I
had this meeting at Banff with this guy
from NASA and he and he was saying well
if you had data to back up your art we
could find you and that's really a
difficult question it he was really
serious he wanted if I had this project
that was talking about he's like oh I
would love to fund that but no one that
NASA will let me fund that unless you
have data I have a data about it anyway
he said well you could figure out a way
so that conversation happens all the
time and
and and I haven't I haven't gone to that
place of trying to justify that work but
what is tempting in a way because it's
like if it's it's tempting to find a
common language between artists and sign
and I don't think that's the right
language but it's if it's sometimes it
feels very close and sometimes it feels
not very close at all in between I mean
clearly in a National Science Foundation
is not funding a whole lot of artists so
there are these huge gaps culturally and
III think it is a challenge but I think
I want to be fair to scientists and say
that probably most of the time they they
just don't I mean they're just not going
to the same places and there are a lot
of science I'm eeen so many scientists
are musicians and artists and so I think
it's it's definitely complicated but and
and and it's still not easy to get that
you know funding from from scientific
organizations
I've never gotten funded from NSF for my
artwork so I would love to that's the
next scheme but anyway it's it's it's a
large question for us all
doing psychophysics and and cognitive
psychology trying to understand by your
eye worse addressing the same issues he
said early when you're once from an
experiential viewpoint and once from a
very rigorous scientific viewpoint and
their different methodologies but
they're exploring similar issues like
played both sides about the experiential
stuff answers different questions being
overblown it answers the questions of
the soul or even the condition and you
can't really do that much as Douglas
Davis remember there what
everything.this tries to with yeah and
there are a lot of like feminist
critiques of science which call for
bringing that all that work back in to
talk about experiential and talk about
subjective science like saying you know
if we brought subjectivity and made it
okay again maybe we would be getting
different kinds of scientific processes
it's an interesting stuff yeah yeah
oh I hope in this talk I haven't done
the new thing I really tried not to do
the new thing
I don't did I do the new thing okay I is
not I wouldn't say I'm sure like I mean
frankly I can't answer that question I I
can't answer what is good art I'm not I
I don't care I mean I I mean I know what
I find moving and important work and I'm
if I can find it and get access to it
I'm I'm happy about it you know that's a
how could you say that about Fluxus it's
or conceptual art how do you know what's
it what's a good work or not and that's
it I mean I'm not a curator I I don't
know I I know what what works what when
I feel like I've kind of communicated
something or built a system that's
that's created something and I and I
definitely feel like there are aesthetic
parameters that I personally follow but
you know someone who's investigating
this right now is Don Ritter he said
he's a video artist lives in Brooklyn
and he he's writing a book about the
aesthetics of new media or something
something along these lines and I think
there's one other book like this in
process anyone know that one anyway I I
would try to email Don Ritter and get
that conversation going but I I find
that work that that looks on these
systems and new and fresh ways and and
that can also have some way of shifting
the way we sifting our assumptions about
it and if it has an aesthetic and a
complexity that I that's how I would
look at those things but I wouldn't say
it doesn't have to be nice looking or or
sounding
how do you find how much control over
the narrative it's a little bit
different than that person from some of
the for example the VRML works some in
the in the Verma pieces you can set
animation paths so you can take someone
it's almost like a Disney ride where you
can take someone through a particular
place but it can be overridden at any
time and you can also do that in the
game engine but I've found that people
were getting really really frustrated in
them in the 3d virtual like the Verma
worlds people who are kind of seeing
them as dreamy spaces but as soon as as
soon as it's a it's a game engine art
hack I mean it also has to do with just
the reception of very few people are
using game engines to do that kind of
level of storytelling they're generally
going out to linear video and you know
machinima stuff but you could
pre-programmed sequences when you hit a
particular spot you know do a cutscene I
like to keep it really open and try to
have an experimental narrative where you
through repetition or through getting a
sense of a combination of text and image
you can get pieces of the story and
eventually by exploring the space you
would get most of the story if someone
doesn't get the whole story I think it's
okay but somebody needs to get something
out of it so that's the kind of mind
that I would draw draw for it like but
it's it's very interesting because I
have those there's some pieces in there
where there's just huge walls of text
that kind of spray out and they're kind
of hard to read and people just run
right by them the work the work showed
in Australia the first time I showed was
in this gaming show so all the works
were games and that had a very
particular meaning as far as how someone
would approach that work so people sit
down in the in every single one of them
and they treated it like an arcade
that's very different
and a storytelling medium so I think it
also depends in the context of reception
- I had to slow I had to actually go in
and slow the character's feet the the
run cycle down because people were
running so faster than work that I think
they weren't getting it but he doesn't
get it at all so but why I just you know
when they're in mud they got it and they
weren't they and they didn't get they
were more frustrated being able to run
fast and just run by everything I
thought they'd be really frustrated if I
slowed them down because I would be like
come on but um they weren't actually
those people seem to like it better that
way
oh come on one more okay honey that is a
big question it's a biggest question
I've ever gotten my life probably okay
you want the answer I got an answer for
you okay this is really good
no I mean one of the things I didn't
talk about was this kind of activist the
kind of commercial style media that I
make especially for for girls and for
underprivileged kids to teach
programming or to encourage girls in
science and math stuff I do a lot it
because I was a professional software
developer for a while and I feel like I
have these skills to use on on projects
that could be just the same kind of
quality as a commercial
style thing but do other kinds of with
other kind of intent or other kinds of
economic needs like I'm not I don't need
to start a company and and I can make
different kinds of decisions if I'm not
going after a target market and or you
can define target market in a different
way so I I see myself as someone who's
making this kind of work but I'm not
content to only make this kind of work I
feel like I have to go out and try
several different ways of addressing
these things I also write so I feel like
I come at the the set of experiments or
whatever you want to call it is actually
sets different kinds of of places for
that and so so it's complex I wouldn't
say that I'm my role is you know I'm a
hacker or I wouldn't say I I don't I
don't I think it's I think I have a more
circular
I'm definitely participating in the
production of cultural a pop culture and
I'm definitely critiquing it at the same
time and I think that dialogue is is is
what I'm constantly having with myself
between between all of all the things I
described I wouldn't I wouldn't say this
is high art I would say that the intent
is different that's how I would
categorize it the intent is if I'm
because I'm not making this for a
particular audience a one particular
audience but if I'm making something for
eleven-year-old girls I go talk to 11
year old girls and I you know play with
them and talk with so that's a very
different process that's all this just
different process is in different intent
but not I wouldn't say one's thank you